Gregg Alva tonio we just watched the
Justice League trailer in preparation
for everyone's request of the Justice
League
we're trailer by Aldo Jones who wants
people to do reactions permission
authorized no there is a stranger who
comes to this village to see comes the
winter people on the bus huh comes on
the king - I was last night
[Music]
is coming far away
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you are but whoever you're working for
[Music]
feels like an oversimplification I'm
going together
[Music]
stop right there I'm in
[Music]
didn't think you were
oh wow dudes you keep getting better and
better donate to him please as patron I
I'm totally donating fresh mirror a lot
of laughs on that one that was good I
like the way it was headed up felt like
really smooth when you were watching it
yeah like I think he gets I think he's
got that was his best one he's ever done
yeah like a song it's like oh you can
react whoo whoo okay and uh yeah dude
you guys gotta check out his other ones
because I love the first one I saw off
his Batman V Superman one and I really
did like also his Captain America one
this one though I thought everything was
used beautifully like yes there are
things that were just random but it
worked best when they were random but
they're also like images and other
things that you did kind of think of it
but then what the [ __ ] moments were
never just what the [ __ ] it was
hysterically like what the [ __ ] is going
on yeah the little things they slipped
in like him like showing the video of
Aquaman looking for this guy yeah
Bernardo member person oh yeah
ghostbusters burying themselves dude
that was good man an Eddie Murphy a
cyborg yeah even like my Eddie Murphy is
like the regula for he got the cyborg
and it looks so dope but even that any
Murphy on the side we're hilarious it
almost makes me want any Murphy for this
and I like how he does the throwbacks
with the newspaper because that's in his
other weird trailers and the winking at
the camera at the end like oh yeah dude
aldo jones and that was my favorite one
for sure that was my favorite one that
was like fluid hey that was great man
when we look like I love to tell like
the eyeballs were spinning around like
for a flash when he was a like staring
at
we're game Tony yeah I'm sorry cuz my
hilarious man
he's opening up a newspaper and she's
talking yeah man that she's hilarious
just got pretty good man it was really
well put together some great effects to
something some stuff just look flawless
like the wings that he does at the
camera always look great but someone
just the splicing he does of the actual
you would Santa look really good and it
would said it was really there I was for
you I like though dad a man drops down
remote the bet the paperboy part what do
you say I like that a spot where Batman
jump drops down onto his bike roll oh
yeah
Aldo Jones subscribe to his channel
please that was well [ __ ] worth and
my god that was hilarious good dudes um
subscribe to the real rejects to while
you're at is Tony Gill follow him at
trees he on Instagram he's my next-door
neighbor he's a beautiful man with a
beautiful girlfriend soon to have a
beautiful baby not his it's mine
had to tell you man we're supposed to
tell the world well we [ __ ] just want
everyone to know the [ __ ] not surprised
anymore
no [ __ ] I finally lost my gorgeous
pregnant Kourtney's pregnant hey man I
don't wanna jinx myself she's not
pregnant match now she's not otherwise